das Leben genießen solange es geht das
könnte so schnell vorbei sein
[Musik]
im Strandclub von Odessa feiern sie so
gut dass eben möglich ist in einem Land
im Krieg
Anatoli ist 23 und DJ
als Student muss er nicht zur Armee am
Wochenende liegt der auf
das ist die Musik die ich über alles
liebe und ich passe mich an das Publikum
an das heißt ich sehe was für Leute
kommen und spiele die Musik die die
Leute brauchen
Party am Schwarzen Meer zwischen
Luftabwehr und Kriegsschiffen auf
Patrouille beides dürfen wir nicht
zeigen aus Sicherheitsgründen
dafür danken dass ich auch in so
schwierigen Zeiten das tun kann was ich
liebe und weiter arbeiten kann
[Musik]
alles muss schnell gehen an diesem Abend
das wissen die Besucher es gibt
schließlich immer noch die
Ausgangssperre und so trinken Sie
schnell feiern hart Party im Fast
Forward Modus
Ukraine
runden Helden Russland ist Soldat in
Odessa stationiert mehr will er nicht
sagen jana hat ein paar Freunde
eingeladen sie feiern ihren Geburtstag
ich frage sie wie das alles
zusammenpasst Feste feiern und Nächte im
Bunker
ich verstehe jeden Tag dass ich heute
sterben kann oder morgen und ich werde
es nicht bereuen dass diese Party heute
stattgefunden hat denn es ist die
einzige Party seit zwei Jahren
seit dem Wochenende haben auch einige
Strände in Odessa offiziell wieder
geöffnet voll was hier aber auch vorher
schon auch während der letzten heftigen
Angriffe auf die Stadt
ich war vor zwei Wochen hier und da war
es wirklich beängstigend aber jetzt ist
das Schwimmen an den Stränden wieder
erlaubt es gibt Bojen hier der
Schwimmbereich ist abgetrennt jetzt kann
man hier schwimmen
früher hat Odessa Urlauber aus der
ganzen Welt angezogen jetzt kommen sie
vor allem aus anderen ukrainischen
Städten wika und Julia sind aus Butcher
wie ist das Wasser
für mich ist es nicht kalt hier so
reinzugehen
das ist mal eine Abwechslung für uns
dieses Paar will seinen Namen nicht
nennen zu gefährlich für die Familien
Mario Paul sie selbst sind im letzten
Sommer aus der von Russen besetzten
Stadt geflohen
naja schon gut hier aber unsere Seele
ist dort
zweieinhalb er kommt das so deshalb
richtig genießen kann er den Tag am
Strand nicht
das Kind erschrickt bei jedem Lärm jeder
Explosion sogar wenn etwas auf den Boden
fällt er hat Angst läuft weg
er nimmt regelmäßig Medikamente und wir
gehen zum Psychiater
sie hat seine kleine Tochter Jever auf
dem Arm sie ist zehn Monate alt Sie sind
Binnenflüchtlinge aus nikolajev wollen
in Odessa ausharren bis sie wieder in
ihre Heimat zurückkehren können wir sind
einfach müde von der Situation
müde über die Unsicherheit im Leben wir
wissen nicht was zu tun ist das ist das
schrecklichste für alle Ukraine diese
Unsicherheit
immer wieder haben die Russen in den
vergangenen Wochen nur deshalb
angegriffen die Stadt deren Zentrum auf
der UNESCO-Liste des gefährdeten
Weltkulturerbes steht
vor der berühmten Oper von Odessa wartet
Pawlow auf Touristen den in er seine
Stadt zeigen kann
sich parallel ich will dieses Bild von
Odessa mit anderen teilen damit sie mit
einem Stück Odessa nach Hause gehen und
nicht mit traurigen und ängstlichen
Gesichtern
eine bunte Truppe für der durch die
Stadt zeigt die Passage die nach
Mailänder Vorbild erbaut wurde Ende des
19 Jahrhunderts also Dessert Teil des
russischen Zarenreichs war sie lassen
die Pracht und den Reichtum erahnen
dessen Spuren hier überall noch zu
finden sind
seit neuestem hält Pablo auch vor
russischen raketentreffern
ist eine schöne Stadt viele schöne
Städte in der Ukraine werden zerstört
das ist unmenschlich
im Strandclub von Odessa geben Sie noch
mal Gas gleich ist Schluss es geht
Kriegsrecht das Leben zu feiern ist
trotzdem wichtig findet Maria
für mich geht das Leben weiter der Krieg
auch aber irgendwie wird es ohne Tanzen
nicht dasselbe sein auch nicht im
kriegen
Anatoli liegt kurz vor zehn den letzten
Song auf was langsames zum Runterkommen
es ist als ob er einen Schalter umgelegt
hätte
[Musik]
der letzte Song war everything will be
alright unsere sehr populären Band Organ
lG und mit diesem Lied wollte ich den
Menschen zeigen dass wir früher oder
später den Krieg gewinnen werden und in
unserem Land alles gut werden wird
zum Abschied wünscht er uns seinen
friedlichen Himmel an diesem Ort in
dieser Stadt bedeutet das eine Nacht
ohne russische Angriffe
[Musik]